bonjour david cormand vous ronge merci
beaucoup d'être je joue avec nous à les
y installer vous prenez votre temps
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
des vidéos européen europe ecologie les
verts on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre dont le
fabricant jour oriane bonjour david
cormand fabrice des journaux du groupe
ebra ce sont les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
on commence bien évidemment david
cormand par la primaire écologiste sai
on connaît le résultat le second tour
opposera donc yannick jadot à sandrine
rousseau résultat très serré on va y
revenir vous souteniez eric piolle il
est arrivé 4e heyer pour qui allez vous
voter au second tour je vais pas le dire
parce que
je pense que c'est une primaire qui a
largement dépassé les adhérents des
partis on n'est pas dans un congrès je
pense que ce deuxième tour comme le
premier d'ailleurs il appartient à
celles et ceux qui ont rejoint cette
dynamique extraordinaire de de notre
primaire écolo et que c'est à eux de
choisir la meilleure personne pour ce
second tome j'ai pas envie d'un terreau
furet puis par ailleurs et pourquoi ne
pas lier vous avez été très clair sur
votre choix de premier tour oui mais
justement et figurez-vous j'ai perdu ta
qu'en fait c'est invite aussi parfois à
l'humilité dont vous voyez j'aime bien
parler je suis content d'être ici ce
matin mais on a le droit aussi de se
taire dix joueurs quand on voit là mon
candidat il a été éliminé donc je vais
pas donner des leçons sur ce qu'il faut
faire ou vous êtes comment sont ok oui
vous êtes et si vous êtes déçus et non
parce que je suis déçu évidemment mais
je trouve ça très intéressant le
résultat parce que c'est à peu près
quatre quarts et à l'époque où c'était
les adhérents élevé d'ailleurs on était
parfois moqué par certains certains de
vos collègues sur ces la cabine
téléphonique
ils sont trois ils font 4motion enfin on
connaît tous ces poncifs là sur les
verts et là quand on a un cadre beaucoup
plus élargie de 120 mille personnes eh
bien il ya une logique c'est que c'est
vrai que l'écologie politique vous le
savez c'est un tableau avec plein
d'idées avec dans ce tableau composé
d'affluents où il ya l'écologie plus
fins sociétal féministe il ya une
écologie plus pragmatique de
gouvernement une écologie plus radicale
dans le sens des croissances
environnementalistes et une écologie
plus ce rassemblement de la gauche
autour de l'écologie au lycée les quatre
incarnation qui avais un peu assez
primaire et ça ça fait à peu près quatre
quarts et c'est ça qui fait la famille
de l'écologie je trouve ça bien que ce
soit équilibrée parce que ça veut dire
que l'écologie ont bien que jamais tout
seul et l'exotique cette famille comment
vous l'expliquez avant de revenir sur
ses c4 car comment vous l'expliquez vous
l'échec de l'échec qui les jouent des
rôles avec hans adjoua 3000 voix sur 106
mille votants donc oui ça vous gêne un
échec ah c'est pas un échec si quand on
est candidat et qu'on n'aime pas c'est
plutôt un échec mais si vous laissez pas
non plus une fessée sa ses joues ça
s'est joué à la capacité à mobiliser des
gens à l'inscription plus ou moins que
les autres et tout savoir j'en sais rien
c'est si j'avais la réponse on aura
gagné on sera au deuxième tour on a
l'impression que cette élection s'est
joué soit la question de la radicalité
entre notamment votre candidat sandrine
rousseau qui elle est semble t-il la
candidate de la radicalité de ce
deuxième tour
je suis pas d'accord externalise là je
l'entends souvent et donc je comprends
que vous me posiez la question mais
l'écologie politique depuis l'origine
depuis toujours elle est
fondamentalement radical
fondamentalement radical et quand on
m'explique oui mais regardez les verts
allemands moi je siège avec des vers
allemand parlement européen je regarde
leur programme pour les élections
législatives en allemagne c'est un
programme radical au sens étymologique
du terme c'est que quand on est
écologiste on s'attaque aux racines de
ce qui pose problème dans notre modèle
de développement le rapport à la
consommation la façon de produire la
façon de consommer je les dis vous êtes
d'accord quand même finalement c'est
porteur d'une radicalité
fondamentalement c'est porteur d'une
rare qualité mais y compris sur la
question des droits humains vous savez
l'écoféminisme c'est un concept qui a
été posée en france au début des années
70 sacs est porté depuis très longtemps
le rapport à la décroissance c'est au
début des années 70 là encore le club de
rome qui fait ce rapport sur les limites
de la croissance et qui dit un certain
nombre de choses qu'aujourd'hui le giec
peut dire et qui est étayée
scientifiquement donc en fait c'est
quelque chose c'est une histoire qui
vient de loin donc le vieux débat la
façon dont on est décrit comme étant à
l'écologie c'est radicalité au paradis
qualité je peux encore excellent yannick
jadot qui est présenté comme étant assez
celui qui est pragmatique et tout ça
yannick jadot c'est celui qui a mis dans
le débat public en tant que député
européen ya déjà dix ans la question des
traités de libre échange aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose mais c'est lui qui a
porté sa en premier donc c'est pas un
pragmatique je sais pas quoi donc c'est
plus compliqué que ça je pense que c'est
un peu trop limité comme analyse
d'essayer de dire ah bah ya les radicaux
d'un côté les paradis co2 doute c'est
pas comme certains comme moi c'est pas
comme ça que je perçois ça est ce qu'il
n'est pas plus compatible avec un plus
large rassemblement yannick jadot pour
vous et regardez quand il ya cent vingt
mille personnes qui yannick jadot bas il
fait
un peu de moins de 28 % c'est d'arqana
72% encore une fois sur un corps
électoral très large qui ont eu notre
préférence ça c'est un problème pour
vous ces quatre car finalement est-ce
que ça monte pas que dans l'écologie est
divisée sur sa ligne et non parce qu'en
fait c'est pas une question de ligne
c'est une question de centres d'intérêt
prioritaire mais s'il n'y a pas les gens
qui sont éco féministes sont pas que ico
féministe il porte aussi une école et
ceux qui sont pour la décroissance a pas
dire qu'ils s'en moquent des questions
des droits humains donc en fait c'est
pas moi je je crois que tout ça se
complète en réalité comment vous allez
bâtir un projet commun parce qu'on
imagine quand l'excellent d'akira sortir
vainqueur il va devoir rassembler les
autres mais je pense que c'est ce qu'on
a démontré pendant nos débats regarder
pendant les débats qui a eu quant à ses
intérêts c'est d'ailleurs quoi
interloquer en se disant ah bah au moins
ça parle de son lait d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec nous mais on parler d eux
des vrais sujets quand dans les ans une
actualité politique on préfère parler
d'autres trucs sur l'identité mâchant
koala nous moi je pense qu'on a pas une
chose plus épanouissante et donc on a vu
des convergences fortes on a vu que les
gens se chamaillaient pas et on a vu des
10 ans us mais qui était plutôt fait
qu'on tient on trouve des synthèses
dynamique derrière est ce que dans cette
élection vous n'avez pas sous-estimer le
poids de sandrine rousseau notamment et
cette approche éco féministe non parce
que c'est quelque chose qui vient de
loin je voulais 10 au niveau de
l'écologie politique ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui apparaît avec sandrine
rousseau c'est quelque chose qui est
très présent tandis que c'est à son
honneur dans l'écologie je pense que ça
c'est une thématique en pas je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui correspond à une
prise de conscience plus partagée que le
milieu écolo avec le mouvement mitu etc
etc mais encore une fois il serait
injuste je pense pour tout le monde de
dire que sandrine rousseau entre les
deux candidats au deuxième tour mais
même les quatre premiers serait la seule
à pouvoir porter ces sujets-là la même
façon qu'ils seraient juste injuste de
dire que yannick jadot est le seul à
pouvoir porter une écologie de vue de de
l'accession au pouvoir tiens ça serait
les caricatures et l'unaf à l'arrêt
l'autre l'une et l'autre sur des
postures qui sont plus complexes que
janick jadot qui souhaite aussi se
présenter comme un homme de pouvoir du
gouvernement oui parce que ce que je
vous disais c'est que dans une campagne
comment dire vous choisissez d'éclairer
une partie spécifique pour vous
identifier mais ça veut dire que vous
êtes nuls dans les autres domaines oui
justin un dernier mot sur eric hall
c'est le seul mr et écolo est dans son
second mandat à l'heure actuelle
finalement ça n'a pas payé comment vous
l'expliquez finalement l'écologie les
victoires écologie ça s'arrête aux
municipales non c'est pas pareil après
quand on passe à une élection tout non
enfin d'abord oui c'est vous avez raison
de rappeler que c'est le maire écolo qui
a été réélu et largement réélu bien plus
largement que lorsqu'il a été élu à son
premier mandat donc ça serait abusif de
dire que ça marche pas ça a marché
plutôt bien pour lui en tout cas les
grenobloises et les grenoblois ont
largement plébiscité pour un deuxième
mandat donc il était plutôt content
l'expérience non je crois pas parce que
l'écologie vous savez elle est
fondamentalement girondine lé fédéral et
elle est fondamentalement généreux
girondine sûr que on a des fonds défend
toujours les robes des régions on défend
le municipal isme l'ancrage local
on n'est pas pour un état uniquement un
état tout puissant on pense qu'il faut
un état fort mais il faut aussi des
territoires dont je crois pas qu'ils
aient une lecture de s'étendre là à
faire par rapport à l'élimination des
red piol dans le même temps
en tant que vous faisiez votre primaire
les socialistes étaient réunis en
congrès du côté de villeurbanne anne
hidalgo et leur candidate même sur un
vote le 14 octobre est ce qu'un aileron
et plan cars et une candidature commune
socialiste écologique mais je crois pas
je crois pas je pense qu'anne hidalgo et
fiable et d'ailleurs vous parlez du
congrès socialiste vient de la famille
de la social démocratie elle est la
candidate du parti socialiste et que du
parti socialiste aucune autre force
politique en tout cas ce stade soutient
sa candidature et c'est bien normal que
le parti socialiste est une candidate ou
un candidat en l'occurrence une
candidate anne hidalgo après ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est que en tout cas
en france le parti socialiste dit assez
peu qu'il est socialiste il dit qu'il
est écologie d'ailleurs anne hidalgo dit
jamais je suis la candidate une
candidate socialiste en france elle
parle beaucoup d'écologie oui mais
j'espère que c'est un hommage notamment
aux écologistes je pense que la raison
des mauvaises ou une stratégie qu'elle a
d'ailleurs nourri longtemps avec eric
piolle lui-même on les a à s'ouvrir
gurry elle à grenoble puis on a vu par
la suite quand yannick jadot il a
organisé un peu l'événement là en avril
où elle était là aussi donc je pense que
oui anne hidalgo elle pensait considère
qu'il faut comment dire coloré le
socialisme
deux heures pour qu'ils soient un petit
peu plus attrayant mais tu es loi ne
peut pas être votre candidate non non
non non non ça n'est pas une écologiste
pour vous et moi je suis pas l'agencé de
notation ce serait prétentieux de dire
vous êtes cm pas vous en vous elle dit
ce qu'elle veut voilà ce que je dis
c'est qu'anne hidalgo elle est d'une
histoire politique et respectable qu'est
la social démocratie même si elle ne dit
pas souvent elle est socialiste et moi
voilà l'écologie c'est autre chose c'est
une autre vision de la société c'est une
nouvelle offre politique qui rompt avec
ce qui était la gauche d'inspiration
marxiste du 20e siècle et sa dérive
sociale démocrate de jeunes une dérive
sociale libérale l'écologie c'est une
autre histoire est ce qu'elle a fait à
paris le convainc pas en matière
d'écologie est ce que c'est pas la
preuve qu'à met en oeuvre l'écologie non
vallée de la bruche je pense que ce qui
est mis en oeuvre en matière d'écologie
à paris c'est beaucoup due aux
écologistes qui à chaque fois qu'on a dû
avancer sur les questions écolos ont dû
faire pression y compris sur le parti
socialiste pour y parvenir et donc c'est
ce bilan là il est largement imputable
de mon point de vue au aux écolos et
puis à des sujets ou des que
que ça soit la tour triangle que ce soit
une certaine conception de l'urbanisme
qui est pas vraiment écolo qui est
plutôt béton là on voit que la nature
profonde de nos amis socialistes reprend
le dessus donc pour être clair pour vous
il y aura forcément un candidat écolo et
anne hidalgo
c'est normal en fait moi ça après je
pense sur lui et tout le monde appelle
au rassemblement et depuis deux ans il
faut mais quand vous dites il n'est pas
possible ce rassemblement dany levait
pas possible en fait quand on n'est pas
d'accord sur le fond c'est normal
d'avoir plusieurs candidatures s'appelle
la démocratie donc moi je préférerais
que le parti socialiste dise booba ceux
qui sont les mieux placés je pense que
c'est ce qui va ce cd montrer dans les
semaines qui viennent pour se qualifier
au deuxième tour c'est plutôt l'écologie
donc ce coup ci nous la dernière fois on
avait soutenu la candidature socialité
leur savait pas tellement bien marché
même s'ils se disent ce coup ci c'est
plutôt l'écologie qui peut gagner moi je
serais très content qu'il vienne mais
j'en veux vivre en ville ils font ce
qu'ils veulent on va passer au reste de
l'actualité c'est cette crise des
sous-marins bien sûr qu'ils continuent
de faire l'actualité jean yves le drian
eu des mots très durs ce week-end à
l'encontre des les australiens mensonge
duplicité rupture de confiance est ce
que pour vous la réaction française est
à la hauteur de ce que le ministre a
lui-même qualifié de coup de poignard
honnêtement j'en sais rien parce que ce
dossier là moi je suis pas au ministère
je suis pas dans la majorité je suis pas
parlementaire au niveau national qui
suit les questions de défense donc j'ai
vu depuis quelques jours qu'il ya une
flopée de d'experts et d'experte qui se
révèle et qui disent il aurait fallu
faire six mois j'en sais rien ce qui
s'est passé est ce qu'il y avait des
signes annonciateurs qui montrait que
l'australie était en train de choisir
une autre solution qu'on n'a pas su voir
où est ce que de toute façon leur
décision était prise et tout ça par
contre la question qu'il faut se poser
qui est plus intéressante à mon avis que
celle stricto sensu du contrat même si
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour notre
économie même si moi j'ai jamais été fan
de l'économie de la vente d'armements la
france est un des pays experts mais ça
c'est un autre débat il ya une question
géopolitique ya une question je plie de
profondes on nous a dit oulala avec
trump aux états unis ça va être
compliqué les relations avec les états
unis tout ça on voit qu'avec
l'administration by donne c'est un peu
pareil pour être feront peut-être déjà
commencé avec obama sarko fait les états
unis pour des raisons budgétaires pour
des raisons aussi le holà de vision
politique se retire du champ d'influencé
de l'europe et se dit notre sujet
maintenant c'est plutôt l'espace
pacifique avec la chine est donc ce
redéploiement stratégique et cette
pression peut être qu'il ya eu jean
sérien l'est des états unis pour dire à
l'australie attendait vous êtes en
confrontation un peu direct avec la
chine faut nous aider pour avoir une
stratégie sur cet espace là donc il ya
un glissement du centre de gravité
géopolitique de là où ça se passait de
l'espace atlantique vers l'espace
pacifique et nous en tant qu'européen il
faut qu'on analyse c'était à deux faits
s'agit pas de on peut se plaindre tout
ça peut-être les autorités indélicats
mais quelque part c'est pas ça le sujet
le sujet politique et géopolitique c'est
qu'est ce que fait l'europe qu'est ce
que fait le berceau de l'occident qu'est
l'union européenne en matière
géopolitique nous on a un voisin qui est
pas un acteur mondial majeur en réalité
mais qui pèse beaucoup dans un espace
vital qu'est la russie qu'est-ce qu'on
fait par rapport à ça et il ya les deux
mastodontes en plus de l'europe nous on
reste la première puissance économique
du monde donc on n'est pas une petite
chose et deux mains hautes mastodontes
que sont la chine les etats unis et qui
est qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour vous
ce matin jean yves le drian dans
ouest-france il appelle à une réflexion
collective de la part des européens
idylle l'union européenne doit aboutir à
la définition de ce qu'on appelle la
boussole stratégique un livre blanc de
la défense et de la sécurité et oui il
sera temps après il faut que la france
comprenne que si on fait ça ça sera pas
l'europe de la défense ce sera pas là la
défense de la france en plus gros tiers
que nos partenaires européens si on
souhaite construire ça ça veut dire une
souveraineté partagée sur une question
stratégique fondamental de défense josy
entraves faites il faut vous y est
favorable en tout cas c'est une question
qui se pose moi je suis pas fermé la
pause mais moi je suis pas fermé parce
que mais depuis longtemps on dit ça au
niveau des écolos pourquoi parce que
l'union européenne on l'a vu on va en
parler peut-être après avec madame
borderline
on est un nain diplomatique l'union
européenne et une surpuissance
économique la première puissance du
monde au niveau économique et nous
sommes à un art budgétaire tient notre
capacité d'investissement pour la
transition pour faire des partis pris
économiques sont
riquiqui dire que le budget de l'union
européenne c'est 1% du pib le budget
fédéral américain c'est 25% du pib r
c'est pas les mêmes compétences bien sûr
mais c'est pour donner un ordre d'idée
1% même temps pendant qu en fait notre
capacité d'action budgétaire est limité
et nous sommes un an diplomatique et
donc concrètement est ce que lui n'en
ont pas les moyens de renforcer son oui
à la condition que les états consentent
à déléguer une partie de leur
souveraineté y compris en matière de
défense qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'otan
dire qu'en fait le temps qui a été créé
au moment de la guerre froide pour
contrer la russie dont on fait partie
est-ce que ça encore un sens il faut y
rester qu'est-ce qu'on en fait yannick
weber tories demande un sommet
extraordinaire de l'union il va même
jusqu'à évoquer le retrait de la france
du commandement intégré de l'otan une
question qui serait question mais il
faut redéfinir ckoi l'objet social de
l'autan on sait pourquoi il a été créé
on sait à peu près comment elle a évolué
quand les états unis voulaient
revendiquer un rôle de gendarme mais pas
tout seul machin là c'est le disent nous
le temps c'est plus notre sujet pas de
sujet c'est on se retendent sur le tas
comme il est pourtant pacifique donc il
faut poser la question à nos partenaires
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'auto ça
peut être un autant qui est revisité
avec un nouvel
une nouvelle feuille du route sur
comment on fait quoi où ça peut être le
fait bien ça a plus de sens politique ne
s'agit pas de rondes de claquer la porte
en disant nous la france la france on
claque la porte de l'otan se passe à 15
à envisager le retrait du commandement
intégré
si on construit quelque chose d'autre
qu'à plus de 100 ce qui serait une union
européenne diplomatiques avec une
capacité de défense est une énigme
comment dire une deuxième décision qui
serait partagé est justement fait la
main dans la sienne en a parlé dans son
discours fabrice et méo préalablement
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer sur le
sujet ce nouveau sur l'histoire des
sous-marins s'il veut mais surtout enfin
parce que emmanuel macron je vais vous
dire c'est le champion des concours
d'éloquence donc sur toutes ces sujets
là il fait des grands discours sur la
vie la mort la géopolitique et le truc
machin mais en fait c'est pas un grand
oral de l'ena qu'on demande au président
de la république c'est une vision donc
c'est quoi sa vision stratégique c'est
que c'est quoi les moyens qu'ils
d'hommes pour y parvenir est ce que les
français et françaises sont d'accord
avec moi j'ai toujours l'impression
qu'ils donnent des leçons
c'est bien qu'il l'ait jean yves le
drian sur ce sujet ben là je pense que
sa 6e en fait soit c'est un sujet qui
fâche et il est gravé soit c'est un
sujet c'est juste on s'est fait avoir
sur un contrat et donc si on sent le
ministre de la défense et l'huile vrp
des trucs depuis dix ans donc en fait
c'est bien que souhaité j'en parle soit
c'est une question comme je viens de le
dire qui dépassent ce sujet là c'est un
vrai question géopolitique sur machin
est là et ça devrait durer central de la
présidence française numéro d'assuré des
collections dans son jeu les préfets je
crois que vous allez dire de la campagne
présidentielle mais ça fait à peu près
en même temps donc ça tombe bien et en
tout cas c'est un question une question
fondamentale la campagne présidentielle
c'est quoi la place de la france dans
l'europe et c'est quoi la place de
l'europe dans le monde c'est une
question fondamentale et là dessus je
pense qu'il faut faire attention parce
que la chine les etats unis aussi ce qui
se joue c'est la bataille de
l'appropriation des matières premières
et nous l'union européenne c'est quoi
notre modèle par rapport à ça c'est la
course on a une vision comme lotto le
repas lui extensive faut les chercher
des défauts les coloniser des pays pour
aller chercher leurs ressources faut
aller chercher leurs matières premières
faut pour maintenir un système de
consommation où est-ce qu'on a une
vision différente et moi je pense
vraiment qu'il faut réfléchir à ça plus
comment dire plus résiliente plus
économe plus économie circulaire on
arrête d'aller chercher des ressources a
le goût du monde mais comment on fait
pour eux avoir un autre modèle y compris
de consommation avec des produits comme
plus longue durée de vie c'est toutes
ces questions-là mardones varner la
lionne à la parler d'eux alors justement
on vend bien en vend pas des mois
qu'elle a prononcée elle a prononcé son
discours sur les priorités des mois à
venir ça va dans le bon sens
non madame van lagen ses discours ça va
toujours dans le bon sens le problème
c'est parce qu'elle dit c'est ce qu'elle
ne dit pas c'est les comment dire les
zones grises dans les ambiguïtés si vous
est ce cas-là panier par rapport à la
pac elle a pas prononcé mnop le mot la
pac pardon politique agricole commune
c'est 40 % du budget de l'union dont
j'ai dit que c'était un petit budget à
l'union européenne enfin quand même
c'est plus de 130 milliards d'euros par
an tant que 40% de 130 milliards tous
les ans c'est beaucoup et donc là dessus
pas un mot alors qu'elle a parlé de la
transition écolo comment on fait la
transition écolo s'en remettent en
question la politique agricole commune
telle qu'elle fonctionne aujourd'hui
donc là dessus il y avait un engouement
sur concrètement comment on fait pour
construire cette souveraineté économique
européenne et c'est extra il n'y a pas
une ligne claire à la parler il faut la
souveraineté des microprocesseurs ça
c'est un vrai sujet parce qu'avec
l'économie du numérique tout ça on se
rend compte qu'on n'est pas autonome en
matière de micro processeurs mais
l'enjeu c'est pas seulement de les
fabriquer ses microprocesseurs en europe
c'est les matières premières pour les
avoir et donc là dessus il ya peu de
stratégie sur dire on fait plutôt de la
low tech ce qu'on appelle la low tech
c'est bien d'aider d'objets connectés
qui sont plus robustes qui durent plus
longtemps pour le cycle pour éviter
d'avoir des problèmes datent de
d'approvisionnement en matières
premières toutes ces questions là elles
sont un peu laissés de côté je trouve
donc il manquait des choses pour vous
dernière question sur la mobilisation
des chasseurs qui a eu lieu ce week-end
en france ben oui qui se mobilisent pour
les chasses traditionnelles d'oiseaux
jugée illégale par le conseil d'état
que leur dites-vous à vos amis chasseurs
a d'abord moi j'ai rien contre les
chasseurs je suis pas sûr qu'il serait
d'accord avec vous quand vous les
terrifier de doses d'abord je voudrais
dire une chose c'est que j'étais moi je
rejoue dénie aux chasseurs le fait
d'incarner à eux seuls la ruralité la
ruralité c'est pas la chasse à ne se
réduit pas à la chasse et d'ailleurs il
désespère can oui les filles pour la
défense de la ligue n'en met pas du tout
ils défendent leurs intérêts des
chasseurs ça se comprend la loi ne pas
être d'accord avec eux mais s'accaparer
le monopole de l'incarnation de la
ruralité je ne suis pas d'accord moi je
viens normandie j'ai beaucoup de gens
qui se vivent dans la ruralité en fait
et chasseurs c'est les emmerdes parce
qu'ils peuvent pas se balader avec les
gosses tranquillement le week-end dans
la forêt et c'est pas des urbains qui
viennent à la campagne et qui aime pas
les bruits de chasse c'est les gens qui
vivent avec quand il est la chasse à
courre les gars qui viennent dans votre
jardin site où jésus s'ils viennent pas
achever la bête dans votre salon et qui
ont le droit de le faire parce que donc
tout ça ça suffit et donc d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs si vous n'avez rien contre
les chasseurs non non je vous dirais un
peu caricaturaux du tout mais il ya des
accidents de chasse tous les ans il ya
des gens qui sont morts parce qu'ils
sont en train de chercher du bois dans
leur jardin et qui sont tués par des
chasseurs et c'est eux enfin il y aurait
autant d'accidents enfin dans n'importe
quelle circonstance mais ce qu'on le
doit continuer comme ça avec des gens
qui s'est donc en fait non j'ai pas la
caricature c'est dire la chasse c'est la
ruralité non la ruralité c'est beaucoup
plus que la chasse c'est la défense des
services publics c'est avoir une
économie un modèle économique est pas la
métropolisation de la france mais avec
des emplois de proximité etc etc et je
ne voudrais pas que la seule chose qui
reste de la ruralité dans 20 ans ou 30
ans c'est le droit d'y chasser la
ruralité c'est des endroits où l'on vit
c'est pas les endroits où on passe où on
a du loisir c'est le roi ya des vrais
gens qui vivent donc il faut discuter
avec les chasseurs et moi je leur dis
attention parce que si on devait faire
un référendum demain sur l'interdiction
de la chasse ce qui n'est pas ma
position mais sur l'interdiction totale
de la chasse je pense qu'on gagnerait ce
référendum donc moi j'invite les
chasseurs à être plus humble et un peu
moins comment dire péremptoire avec les
gens qui disent désolés on a le droit
aussi de profiter de la forêt sans
entendre des coups de feu et sans
accessoirement parfois sortira tu dis
les gens ils ont le droit de dire ça et
on a compris votre message merci
beaucoup merci de m comment savoir être
votre invité ce matin merci fabrice
[Musique]